so here's your chance to meet one of the
most recognizable voices of all time eg
daily
that's so cool with with characters like
Rugrats Tommy Pickles the Powerpuff
Girls Curious George and many many more
men men menly men chances are if you're
between the ages of 18 and 40 you know
exactly who I'm talking about today
we're breaking down exactly how she
built her Empire the very dark realities
of working in the entertainment industry
and exactly how much money she made per
episode as soon as you subscribe and hit
the like button don't forget that track
but first we gotta thank today's sponsor
delete me we have to talk about
something that's increasingly more and
more important in today's digital age
and that would be data privacy we all
know by now that our personal
information is being bought and sold
online by data Brokers which obviously
puts all of our privacy at risk well if
you want to remove that risk completely
I personally recommend today's sponsor
delete me delete me helps you protect
your personal data and keeps it private
they specialize in removing your
personal information from data broker
websites so you can have peace of mind
knowing that your sensitive details
aren't floating all over the Internet
look I've experienced it firsthand when
your data gets out there that you don't
want getting out there it's private
information you don't want everyone to
have access to it I've been there but
with delete me I could take control of
my online presence and protect myself
from all of those different risks delete
me even has a team of privacy experts
who helped take care of everything for
you so protect yourself and stay private
with delete me check out join
deleteme.com
ich20 to get 20 off all consumer plans
or just use the code ich-20 at checkout
again the link is down below in the
description to get started today and now
with that said let's get back to the
podcast thank you so much for coming on
the podcast it's going to take me
probably five minutes Grandma Starstruck
that you wanted to do this interview
with me about
like which particular thing was it well
I think everything but for me it was so
full circle because I grew up on Rugrats
like as a kid like non-stop reruns like
my parents would hear the theme song
over and over and over again I saw the
Rugrats movie yeah and so I didn't tell
my mom would get a kick out of this but
I didn't tell her that I was doing this
with you because I was just like afraid
I'm afraid of jinxing things I'm like
well what if like you know because of
the rain like people don't show up or
have to reschedule like if something
were to come up I don't want to get my
hopes up your mom would freak out too
she would lose it like absolutely
but you did so many voices I think for
like my entire generation grew up
hearing you so it's just weird to like
be here across the table from you is is
don't come too close is mind-blowing
there's a line right here all right I'll
keep my distance I promise he's been
looking forward to this for a very very
long time I'll behave I first really
found your content separate from like
Rugrats and everything on Tick Tock I
think through the pandemic I saw you and
your daughter posting videos together
I'm like wow this is so cool daughters
so we would do them together yeah I
think it was Hunter yeah yeah Hunter
Bailey yeah and so that's how I started
following you on like just separate from
everything else I think you have a
really cool story to tell about how you
got into voice acting uh if you could go
into a little bit about your background
like how you got started in that and
like growing up to begin with I didn't
really come from a family that knew
anything about entertainment you know
what I mean like I wasn't I wasn't like
I didn't have an uncle or cousin who was
like a big director or I didn't have any
nepotism there was no connection to
anything in Hollywood but my family all
I knew was that my mom was really loved
the whole Hollywood thing because she
was like an immigrant so she had no
connection to it but she had this thing
where she just loved it you know she
loved music and she loved so I think
starting off like I I think I always
thought like how am I gonna do this like
I really didn't know how I was gonna do
it I think she sort of saw that I had
certain things about me that might have
been like magical
I think my mom saw the magical part of
me and um
and I don't know how it happened just
like one thing led to the next and then
I'd like as a little girl I got an agent
and then I just sort of allowed things
to sort of flow you know things just
started flowing so I really have to say
like I look back at my career and I just
go wow I can't believe I've done all
this work and sometimes it feels like I
haven't done anywhere because I'm like I
can't so much time goes by and I'm like
wow I can't believe I did that and I did
Saturday Night Live and I did American
Bandstand I did Rugrats I did Powerpuff
Girls I did music Adventure I did you
know what I mean yeah and I just think I
just keep walking forward and then new
opportunities keep coming and I try not
to grab too hard onto one of the past
things because if I grab too hard to the
Past things then I won't see what's up
in front of me like sometimes I'll be so
um stuck on something that I did that I
want to keep doing and then sometimes
these magical things like voiceover just
happened it just like I did a play and
someone said you could do this so if I
were just looking back all the time I
was like no I'm an actress I'm a singer
and I wouldn't have been open to this
opportunity
I don't know how to say it started it
just started like random what was
magical as a kid like what were some of
the things that they looked at and said
like ah it's not normal like there's
maybe some Talent here I think I was
just really good at singing and um
dancing like just innately I think I had
that and I started writing songs as a
little girl like I literally picked up a
little guitar book when I was eight or
nine and taught myself to play guitar
and we didn't have YouTube so I taught
myself I started singing and watching
singers and mimicking singers and then I
started taking lessons I was good at it
I mean I was just I could do it I could
do like I could imitate sounds I could
imitate voices you think it's just like
a biological difference in you that most
people don't have where you can mimic
voices or do you think it was something
that kind of just like fostered over
time after lots of practice I think like
some people have this weird ear and they
can mimic and imitate sounds and some
people have no idea how to do it and I
think because I sing I can hear like
someone say something like hey what are
you doing doing and then I can they can
say can you sound like that boy and be
like hey what are you doing and I could
do it exactly like that like Two and a
Half Men you know yeah so you know I do
that yep so that was one of those things
where they were like can you take Jake's
voice and then can you sing like you
were him because we need the singer for
the opening of Two and a Half Men and he
doesn't sing so we need somebody that
sort of sounds like him so I was like
okay send me a recording of his voice
and he was just like Cheryl what are you
talking about you know he sort of talks
like that when he was a little kid he
was sort of chubby and he sore was like
talk slow and then I was like can you
sing like him so I'd go you know men men
men
so it's like I think I just have the ear
for it just like you might be really
good at real estate yeah innately like
there's certain things we have innately
some people are really good at
organizing like my other assistant
she can literally I can put her put her
to a closet with like tons of vitamins
and things in boxes and I can come back
in like 20 minutes and everything is
beautifully lined up I can't do that but
I just think everybody has their little
magical things and I think my magical
thing was Limitless when it came to my
voice like literally Limitless I could
do like any kind of voice any kind of
um age like I do age ranges and little
kids little girls little boys chubby
kids yeah genius kids spark boys you
know whatever it is you know what I mean
yeah girls little tiny
babies yeah do you know what I mean it's
just like it's Infinity yeah right on
top of that I really applied myself to
being really good at those things so I
didn't just rely on my innate talent I
relied on
um I studied like I was my game was like
be as good as I could and that meant
every aspect of it I mean like be great
know how to play guitar so I taught
myself know how to write music so I'd
listen to great writers I just studied I
studied a lot and I say think the
combination between what I actually
could do as a gift and then what I how
much I applied myself I was relentless
how did your parents Foster that growth
because it seems like they were very
supportive and nurturing of like letting
you explore that and and get really good
at that they didn't do music they didn't
do like instruments they they owned a
fencing company they built fences and
window grills you know and so I think
what she she'd do was she'd go to thrift
stores and yard sales and flea markets
and she'd pick up instruments and she'd
see like some weird instruments she'd
thrown in the house and one of the five
kids would pick it up and start playing
it and I sort of did all of it I was the
one that would like pick up trying to
sing and pick up trying to play that
instrument so I could play like a little
harmonica little drums little guitar a
little piano a little you know what I
mean I picked them all up and my
brothers and sisters all
did too but just more more limited even
my brothers and sisters will say that
when I was born it was almost like she
was like this little this is gonna be
you know which also put a lot of
pressure on me to be honest like I felt
it but I really do feel like I felt it
for my mom whatever that was that she
saw was I think what gave me a little
push and um
and also made me be a little sensitive
to other people wanting that's where my
people pleaser comes in I want everybody
to feel special did uh your parents ever
put any pressure on you to to go for
more of like a normal career or like we
want you to be a doctor or a lawyer they
want you to I think like because they
came with from nothing yeah what I did
was miraculous to them you know I don't
think they had any expectations yeah of
any of us and of any of the five kids in
my family like my sister is a brilliant
painter she goes by Ren River and she's
a brilliant painter she's like a master
painter and she sold paintings all over
and she's been in magazines and I don't
think they could have ever expected that
do you think that some of that is
because growing up in Venice that that
is a very eclectic culture of people
where I think creativity is really
rewarded they weren't really I don't
think they knew what Venice was either
sure okay back then there was even kind
of culture about it there was just
that's where they landed when they came
here and they could get one room that
they could all fit into yeah so I don't
think they had any concept of the Venice
culture yet because Venice culture is so
different back then yeah it was very
different back then and they've been
here like I don't know 40 50 years wow
yeah so when did you first get into to
voice acting you kind of alluded to it
in the beginning did you initially try
to become a voice actor was it like
different types of acting and when did
you secure your first agent so I was
just an actress you know I started
getting an agent when I was a kid like I
had commercial agents when I was eight
and was that you that initiated that
whole process my mom got me an agent and
I had a best friend who was like a child
model my friend Michelle and she was
like this beautiful little girl and she
had commercial agent and so my mom was
like let's get you a commercial agent so
I hated it I thought it was like awful
because you had to be really fake pretty
much it was like hi my name's Michelle
I'm with so-and-so agency and I was just
like I can't do that you know what I
mean it felt really like contrived to me
but she still got me to say dinner and I
went on these commercial auditions and I
didn't understand why I never booked any
of them I just thought okay I guess you
just go on these auditions and you don't
book them you just go on them and then
um
I think it wasn't until I was like 15
after like I got when I was eight and
when I was 15 I got my first job like 15
was like a guest star on a Laverne and
Shirley episode my mom sort of started
me and there was finish requests you
were in commercials between the ages of
eight and fifteen I didn't really I did
let me think I did one commercial
[Music]
um I think when I was 14 for a Pepsi
Cola commercial it was like a national
commercial I don't know how I booked it
but I did one commercial and then I
booked Laverne truly and then I guess
start on like Fame and then I guess
start on chips and Bay City Blues and
then that that was my I started working
you know enacting when I was about 15
16. but how is your agent sustaining
themselves oh it was different I'm
wondering like if it's six years they
don't get a single book yeah I didn't
have I didn't get any work that all the
time I don't even know how I ended up
booking what it how when I switched it
because I was just a kid yeah the Pepsi
Cola commercial I should have never got
because they were like can you I was
very ethnically ambiguous looking you
know I think probably because I had more
of my brown hair it was kind of my jufro
hair and sure you know wild and you know
hippie looking and I think
um they said go to this Pepsi Cola
commercial and they were like can you
sail a catamaran can you get do you know
how to be on a catamaran and I was like
yes because that they said to say yes to
everything yeah and I said yes I can and
then I think because of my ambiguous
look they like that they like that
ethnically ambiguous I got it and then
then I was like sitting on a beach and
they're like okay you're gonna go in and
I was like holy
so I didn't know what I was doing I
should have never probably booked that
but I did and I had to drink a lot of
diet a lot of coke and it was um Coke or
Peppers
but before we go into that I know how
overwhelming it could be to see all the
equipment that's out there and think oh
I gotta spend thousands of dollars to
get started up but thankfully our
sponsor of stream yard is there to help
so stream yard is a live streaming
Studio platform that helps you create
high quality content with just the click
of a button all you need is any camera
and an internet connection and you can
start streaming directly from your
browser what I really like though is
that you could stream to multiple social
media platforms all at the same time so
you could set it up once and then stream
to YouTube to Twitch to Instagram and so
on basically almost anything out there
you're gonna get your face out there
streamyard is the best way to start
creating content online line and best of
all they also offer a free package so
you guys can get started today at the
cost of zero and look leveling with you
guys they've also been a huge supporter
of the podcast and have allowed us to
take a lot of trips and travel to some
of the guests that we otherwise just
wouldn't have really seen so if you guys
appreciate that and want to support us
and have something that's totally free
visit streamyard Down Below in the
description to get started today thank
you so much stream yard we love you and
back to the episode right after I got
out of high school like everybody was
going to colleges yeah and then where it
said my name there was no College I
wasn't going to go to college that
wasn't like my my parents were not those
parents that were like you go to college
you become a doctor you go to college
again they had no expectations were you
academic no not at all I'm a terrible
speller right now even today I'm
embarrassed like when I write something
I have to have somebody proofread
because I'm terrible at it but um I
think there were no expectations yeah so
I didn't go to college I just knew that
I was going to start working and that
was maybe the magic my mom saw she saw
that part of me that was like I'm gonna
make this happen you're Paving your own
Road I paid my own Road and just out of
curiosity with this Pepsi Cola
commercial I'm wondering like how they
digging in there how long did it take
like do you just show up to the beach it
was it a full day shoot I think it was
one or two days wow
do you remember how much they paid for
it I really don't because I'm thinking
like Pepsi they probably got a pretty
sizing it was a budget it was a it was a
national Pepsi commercial do you get
royalties on that and I I would I'm
pretty sure I did back then wow they
stopped airing it though oh yeah yeah
how were you supporting yourself after
high school it's a big uh jump not to go
to school and to go out and like begin
working I think it was those those few
jobs I started getting I mean I had a
couple recurring things on Fame and then
I did Bay City Blues some TV show and
then I did um
chips than I did I started working like
booking little guest stars and things
and then I I started booking features
like I did this one feature called The
Escape Artist I think and that was a
Francis Ford Coppola film with Griffin
O'Neill and Desi Arnaz senior and all
these really classic people that were in
it and I booked that movie and somehow I
became I don't even know how that
happened I went from never booking a job
to like all of a sudden there were
castings of like we're looking for an
Elizabeth daily type and I'd be like I'm
right here maybe
you know and then I was wondering why
they wouldn't just call me they were
looking for a type like me why wouldn't
they call you directly sometimes I
thought they I think they didn't think I
would be available oh wow that happens a
lot it's really weird
um yeah
yeah wow I just I started earning my own
money and it was sustainable immediately
outside of high school for some reason
it was I don't because I didn't I had
like
um like at 15 I worked in an ice cream
parlor but I only worked there because
we're cute boys and I was like really
cute boys that was the only reason why I
got that job did you end up making one
of the cute boys your boyfriend
I don't know maybe
I was like where
that's funny yeah it was boy crazy yes
so still am I think anyway um man crazy
anyway yeah yeah so that's it and how
did that progress because I think you're
you were not really doing any voice
acting at that point so how did that
then transition into voice acting into
voice acting so I was starting to do a
lot of movies right if you look at my
IMDb page there's like a lot of wacky
interesting movies a lot of them all of
a sudden I get a call from a guy named
Bruce who's a friend of mine that I'd
known who's a producer and he said oh um
we have this play that was on Broadway
called tansy and it starred Deborah
Harry on Broadway it was a musical and
it was about a female wrestler you have
to be able to sing you have to be
physically fit so my that's right up my
alley I wasn't always working out and
I'm singer and uh you know and it's a
musical so I love that and so I said
I'll do it and opening night at the Roxy
um a lot of record labels came so I got
a major record deal from it I was just
singing like a couple songs in the play
but I got a massive record deal on a m
and some guy came and handed me this
card
and said you should really do voiceover
you're really good at it because in the
play I had to be a female wrestler but
each round of the wrestling I had to be
a different age so I had to go from
being a baby if I a baby in the first
round like they put me in a baby dress
and a big diaper and with a thing on my
head and a Rattle and I was like
and I just was a baby girl and then I
had to be like hi
hi five-year-old girl and then I had to
be a 10 year old she took like that like
this and then I had to be a 16 year old
and then I had to be a grown-up so I had
to age myself and he saw that he was
like wow you're really good at these
voices and you're really good at
Children's voices again this was that
weird gift that I had that I could
imitate and mimic and then so this guy
handed me a card opening night and he
said I'm a voice agent you should really
pursue this and I was kind of like
I was like I'm not a cartoon I don't I
never thought like I'm gonna be a famous
cartoon one day but I did call him
because
I talk about
um offshoots when I I talk about a thing
called off sheets where like if you get
a tap on that you're going this way yep
and you're very clear and then you get a
tap on the shoulder like you should try
this here and I'm like oh no no I don't
do that I only do this but I was like I
really believe that part of reason why
my career has been so phenomenal with so
many different
I've done so many different types of
things between music and acting in
movies and cartoons is because I
listened to the little tap on the
shoulder
which is like I think the god voice and
it was like you should you should come
see me at this office and try this voice
thing and first I was like I really want
to do a card you know voices but I did
go to his office one day and I did go on
my first audition with this agent and my
first audition
um
I booked and that was Tommy Pickles on
Rugrats that which we can't change my
life yeah changed the trajectory of my
whole like
all of a sudden I started getting all
these cartoons and I was like Huey Dewey
Louie and pop-up girls and Jungle Cubs
and Rugrats and like my whole career and
Not only was that perfect but I was
having babies during that time right so
I was able to be pregnant and work the
whole time there's like Rugrat episode
with me in labor during Rugrats I'd be
like no I don't know about that Chucky
oh please and I'd be like
[Music]
okay I'm better let's go yeah and then
I'd do it again oh my gosh do they
actually have me in labor on Rugrats
okay well we'll get to that in a second
but what is that what you started
sometimes I go on tangency you have to
reel me back to the point what made you
say yes to that uh because you seem very
focused on going One Direction what made
that different that day so the cartoon
yeah I think he was so clear that I had
a real gift with the thing
again there's that gift thing he goes I
think you're really good at this like
your ability to do children's voices and
and age your voice up was really good
that's what he said and I was kind of
like you know to me it was like and I
always say it's like people flipping
their eyelids over they don't realize
it's a weird gift or that weird
double-jointed thing people go like this
and their joints oh yeah not really
don't do anything yeah I can't really
yeah but yeah I think it was just
um he saw in me
the ability to mimic and sound so much
like a kid
that he was like you you should really
pursue this and and I trusted
um yeah trust him I just said okay I'll
go on an audition with you and I just
went with it and it was like it was one
of those yeses that I think changed my
life now you mentioned offshoots yeah
how do you know when to say no
um because you can't just say yes to
everything and then you're just
overloaded but how do you make that
distinction it's a really tricky line
like it really is so it's just a gut
feeling is it usually something you have
to think about or is it kind of like
okay I know what my answer is sometimes
it's like hell yeah my body like oh hell
yeah that feels good but like the
voiceover thing wasn't a hell no but it
was like there was some uncertainty but
there was curiosity so I sort of said
maybe I'll check it out yeah you know I
was curious what was that like
auditioning for Rugrats you had no idea
what it was at the time so what was that
process like what do they have you do I
went to this little Nickelodeon
recording thing and it was my first
audition I didn't almost didn't go
because I was having my carpet replaced
in my condo that day so I almost was
like uh they're a change in the carpet
in my place okay John the next one and
he was like you think should go in you
know go ahead and try it and this agent
was a little pushier yeah and he said no
I think you should try it and I was like
um
no I'll get you on the next one and he
was just enough pushy that I was like
okay
guys I'm just going to the corner I'll
be right back I just told the guys that
were working for me like basically don't
Rob from me I'll be right back I'm
coming back in 10 minutes but really it
was like an hour sure and I just
um and I just ran there and I just uh
read this audition and I had no idea
what I was doing because I'd never done
a cartoon but I just read the lines as a
character that I think it's a little
girl I always did like little baby
voices and I thought that that picture
they showed me a claymation I was like
that Reclamation like the mouth on that
claymation looks like the voice I've
been doing my whole life which was like
oh Michelle let's go let's go get
ourselves a snack what do you say you
know what I mean and you know and I just
looked and I thought the way his mouth
was and the way my mouth sounds and just
something about it and I did that voice
and then
I was like I can't be here very long I
gotta go and they were like okay we're
almost done I was the first person so
they kept making me wait they kept
sending producers in and I was just like
I gotta go and then I I was completely
ignorance as Bliss I had no idea and
there were people waiting to read after
me but they kept bringing new producers
in like in the booth and I was watching
more and more people come in because I
guess they were just like she's it and I
didn't know that and I got home and my
agent called said you they really love
you for that show and to be honest I was
actually a replacement because then
another girl who did Tommy Pickles and I
had to come in they decided it wasn't
the right voice and I had to come in and
redub all of her voice for an entire
season and then I I booked it and that
was like you know
now did they have you audition for other
characters like Chucky or Jewish just
Tommy Pickles did they have everyone
else already locked in on the other
voices yeah because they'd already done
a whole scene oh that's right with the
girl that wasn't so they did the entire
season but didn't like the way Tommy
Pickle's voice sounded that kind of
stuff can happen where you can do or
record and then they go uh we're not
feeling it what were your initial
impressions of the show like when they
pitched the idea did you think this is
going to be a hit or like what what were
your first thoughts remember I was
getting carpet put in my car yeah that's
all I was thinking about well what about
when they say you you got it like this
is yours if you want it I was like
really I really was just like every time
I start every time I book a voice
cartoon every time and I started booking
everyone I'd I'd read for it I'd book it
I'd read another one I was literally
doing eight seasons a week I was doing
eight different shows all week long like
I'd go from a jungle cups to a Rugrats
to a Powerpuff Girls do a I was
literally going day to day to do a
different series on a different network
or it was a lot of work is there any
like conflict of interest like does
Powerpuff Girls not want you being a
voice that's what you would think you
would like sign an exclusive just like
no no because I'm doing that voice for
them and I'm doing Tommy for somebody
else nobody can own you
in voiceover really I feel like the
producers would smart enough because
they would want like just because you're
so good at what you do that just like we
want her and that's it they can't no one
else because I'm Infinity I'm I'm I do
in an Infinity amount of voices so how
could they imprison me in one place when
I I'm like water yeah I'll go everywhere
sure you can't just put me
you know you can't just say water to
stay here I mean I'm gonna go everywhere
yeah do you know what I mean I do so how
did it work when you were filming would
they have you go into the office yeah
progress they would have the babies go
in together
So like
um Chucky Phil Little Tommy
um would all be together and do our
voices and then like Angelica would go
in on her own usually because they would
have the babies because we did so many
of our lines together so we'd have us
together so we first started doing
Rugrats it would take a lot longer it
would take like six hour sessions
nowadays you never take that long I go
in and I do four episodes in one hour
and two hours one to two hours all by
myself because I'm not waiting for
everybody to get their lines right I'm
just doing mine so you could get through
an entire season or pretty quick wow
yeah pretty quick and how does how does
pay work with voice over acting versus
being like physically on screen I mean
right like voice overacting is like
usually when people start doing a show
it's like a scale rate sure it's pretty
much the same with on camera like you'll
get a scale rate I don't know what scale
is for on camera but it's it's probably
similar for a full day whereas you go
and do a voiceover and it could take you
10 minutes you'll make the same twelve
hundred dollars or whatever the scale
rate is if it's sag as you might for
full day on the set so that's pretty
lucrative when you do voiceover because
you have so much time right and um but
then when you have a show that becomes
ahead
the money starts growing so let's say
you have a show that goes for six years
like Rugrats didn't start raising their
money until maybe
six years in and then they were like our
show is pretty popular we're going to
raise the amount you guys are getting so
you know you're gonna get double scale
or you're gonna get Triple scale and
then it would jump from like this amount
to like all of a sudden around season
nine ten it would go from like who are
you making two grand three grand to like
30 grand or something crazy yeah so per
episode yeah you were you could make
really big money per episode I mean
Simpsons like I'm good friends with
Nancy who plays Chucky on Rugrats and
The Simpsons are making like
I don't know is where they were making I
heard something like a hundred thousand
two hundred thousand plus an episode I
think it's more well for Nancy yeah yeah
yeah for some of those people it's like
crazy money so animation can be very
lucrative because it's the same thing
they have a show on prime time yeah
they're making money so why isn't
weren't these star actors that are now
known making the money so I mean there's
a there's a lot of money to be made in
voiceovers if you can have a show that
lasts long enough to go into big money
and syndication and if it's prime time
that's where the money is and it's just
like
um syndication not syndication but if
it's like streaming or it's all
different now because there's so many
venues there's like there's so many
different platforms you know streaming
and like whatever yeah it's different
money now so if you go in and you record
one episode and it's 30k how long does
that take you well back then I think I
was still working with a lot of the cast
members and when you like I said when
you're working with everybody in the
booth you're waiting in between your
lines so that each person gets each line
right that they want so it could take
four hours back then
uh but right now you could go in and do
your the same work you could go in for
do us an episode it's it's not like
right now we're doing Rugrats again it's
not quite it's not what it was back then
because they came in like 14 years later
and renegotiated and they wouldn't
negotiate back to that rate right they
have to start it as a brand new show
kind of we didn't go brand new show rate
but it wasn't like that right and I was
like no it wasn't here but it wasn't
here did you feel like you had more
leverage before the six years of of
Rugrats to increase your pay or did it
take six years to really take off
because it kind of took that long
because because it you started I think
it was 1989 or 1990 was the first oh no
I don't remember the date okay yeah I
can't remember my own birthday sometimes
right before you yeah if you watch the
show Ned's Declassified no on
Nickelodeon yeah he he was saying that
even after three seasons they were very
much apt to say well if you don't like
the pay you could leave and we'll
replace you very easily and that was
their mindset but I feel like with
something like Rugrats very difficult to
replace the voice because it always
sounds a little different like you could
never yeah get it quite the same usually
when you go in on a show like that like
when they came back and said we want to
do Rugrat reboot because now we're on
season two of a brand new reboot
you really don't want to be greedy sure
you really don't you don't want to play
that card because
they could replace you there there's
it's always possible what you want is a
really beautiful
um harmonious
uh win for everyone so I think when it
came to when we all got bass back and
they didn't invite all the adult
characters back they recast a lot of
those characters some people didn't get
recast but the um the main baby
characters all came back but when that
happened we had to come together as a
group that all the babies and say well
what do we think is fair without being
greedy and saying we're not going to do
it unless you give us five million
dollars an episode you know we had to be
really
um have integrity to the whole show not
just think about ourselves like we want
to let's just try to break them for as
much money as we can and so I think we
all came together and thought they
offered a certain amount and then we all
came together and said well what's a
fair amount
that's not crazy and not greedy and also
oh when yes and that's where we came up
with a number that felt beautiful to
Nickelodeon as well and then it's a big
win so you can't just you can't just go
for like you know
yeah you just can't you can't uh you
want to you want to do the right thing
because I've seen people get booed
here's an example so babe you know the
movie Babe and baby too okay so babe the
pig I was baby pig and Pig In The City
the second one the first one had
actually Christine Cavanaugh who's
brilliant actress voice actress who was
the original babe she actually did
Chucky on Rugrats
um she started as Chucky on Rugrats so I
already knew her I was working with her
and she was babe in the first babe and
then what happened was they came time to
negotiate
um
babe pig in the city the sequel to babe
and they went to her and her agent said
this is what we have for you for babe
too and her rap
or whoever was her lawyers or rep was
like no we can't we want way more we
want more and then
they couldn't they said we don't have
any more for this this is our budget we
would love you to do it this is our
budget and then whoever it was the
powers that be in that team said no we
want Mark and they came to me and said
people you auditioned for this role and
at that point I had to say I'm not
auditioning for that role because she's
my friend I work with her own Rugrats
and we don't we can't do that I'm not
going to step in and so I didn't and but
I said but I love to audition for this
other rule
um this little monkey
and they were like okay so then what
happens is time passed they cast recast
her because they never settled on an
amount
and or whatever this happened
time passed they didn't settle with her
they negotiated with somebody else I got
cast as this other character the monkey
the little boy
and then a week before we were recording
I get a call I'm literally sitting on a
beach and I get a call from George
Miller the director says EG we even
listened to the tapes we already recast
the character so it's not like you'd be
stepping on anyone's toes
we think you're babe for this and would
you be interested in doing it now and at
that point I was like yeah I would so I
said yes at that point because I knew I
didn't
um I didn't have a lack of Integrity to
my friend and to
doing the right thing for people that
you work with and so then I got cast as
that character and yeah so you can get
booted out that's my point even on a
giant feature like that hmm if you don't
play the right cards how do you take
care of your voice if you're doing
multiple shows it's nice that it's let's
say four to six hours in a day for an
episode means you could do maybe two at
you know two in a day but how do you
ensure that you don't strain your voice
in one episode so that you go to the
next one it's like you can't do the
other show I think I've been doing so
much stuff with my voice for so much of
my career I mean I'm a singer I think my
voice is so conditioned for so much I
like I'm a bodybuilder like my like some
people are like
I just think I'm like a bodybuilder when
it comes to my vocal cords or my ability
to push my voice it's kind of rare that
I can't you know the only kinds of
things that would really mess my voice
up are if I have a really really severe
chronic bronchitis coughing it just kind
of gives me a little laryngitis which is
pretty rare even and I'm still able to
push myself past that to do certain like
tell me because even it was I like
talking like this and I had like a
really worse voice I still could go Ah
that's so cool you know and I could just
squeeze I smile every time you see that
oh my gosh I just push it right over it
and see what happens so now you were
saying you were in labor
also doing the voice of Tommy Pickles
how how does that work can you can you
do this from home or is it like I was in
the studio and I had gone to the doctor
because I was I was very pregnant and I
said I feel like I'm in labor and that
doctor that I stopped using after that
particular incident I didn't no longer
use that doctor somebody else came in
because the doctor never made it to
labor I don't think but I basically
um I went to the doctors and said I
think I'm in labor and they're like no
you're fine and I was like okay and my
my kid's dad was like
trying to take care because you could
see I was like struggling with
contractions and I just went ahead and
went to work
and I just like yeah what how long does
labor start before birth it can vary it
can be like you can kind of be in labor
for two days having like the
contractions start coming faster and
faster which contractions feel like
um like just pain like it just gets
really like it's almost like your belly
hardens for a second and then it relaxes
and it's a really weird feeling feels
like cramps but you're not a girl so you
don't know what crowds feel like she's
like you know when you have a really
good app day Jack and you're in your abs
I don't think it's not even like that
girl cramps it feels like cramps but it
gets very good I've done um what do you
call it it's a cramp right and like your
calf cramp yeah where it spouses it kind
of feels like in a weird way like I
think it's hard and it's weird that's
what a okay certain they're called
Braxton Hicks feel like it kind of gets
really your belly will actually contract
and gets really hard and it kind of
hurts it's kind of like a cramp in a way
but it's a little different okay like
kind of in your see I didn't know if
this was happening like right before
you're about to give birth it had been
happening for a few days and that could
happen you can start having contractions
but not be in labor and you don't go
into labor until you're dilated a
certain amount your body's gotten so so
big inside and so I guess I went to the
doctors and he was like no you're fine
but I was having so many contractions I
was like how can I just be fine I think
I'm in labor but I just I listened to
the doctor and then
I just went to the work and which was
probably better too because I wasn't
sitting at home thinking about it right
I just went to work and my job wasn't
like I have to go run a marathon or it
was like sitting in a chair doing voices
and they were very patient with me
they're like oh you're having another
one of those and they were like wow
these are you're having them pretty
often yeah every two minutes yeah
Braxton Hicks contractions but they
might be like every hour and you're not
in labor yet how long does a contraction
take it's like it lasts like 20 seconds
oh wow I thought it was gonna be like
maybe two seconds no it's kind of like
no no no so maybe wow 10 seconds I don't
know I gotta remember it's been a while
I'd have to get pregnant again
so yeah it's a really weird thing but I
was like I just was like okay so I went
to work which I would have probably done
anyway and then
after work
it was the crew in the studio that was
like you're having a lot of contractions
very close together people that were
moms that were in the booth were like
when your contractions started happening
like every two minutes three minutes
you're getting closer to being in labor
and then that night had a baby so I was
at night that night wow do you remember
the episode that you felt I don't but
people ask that all the time I don't
remember I wish we could look back at
that episode and be like oh well we did
the ball somewhere near me like oh
chicken I found either oh please
[Laughter]
that is wild yeah so were you ever able
to record these episodes from your house
like if you just set up one of those see
that little audio recording thing well
that's all very new like all this stuff
now is very new so I would go in all the
time but during covid and I had a little
booth so I would do a lot of my own
auditions at home
um for a long time I've had my own
little record for voice over but when
covet hit
everything stopped and that's when
Rugrats had gotten picked up for a
reboot and we started doing episodes
before the covet hit and then I was in
coveted and they're like
and we're like oh no we just started
getting to do new regrets and it's so
fun and so exciting and we were all kind
of bummed and then all of a sudden like
after a few months they called and said
do you have a booth set up at home and I
was like I do and I had just updated it
and I had just put this thing is it's a
it's called um Source connect where I
can connect to a studio outside of mine
and I'd just gotten that all upgraded
for some reason which was miraculous so
then I was like I do and then all of a
sudden they said can we try to do some
episodes at your place and I was like
okay so I started doing them at home and
I actually then I moved to Malibu in a
little place right on the beach and I
had this little booth I had it made for
me and I set it all up in there I did I
think I did like 20 episodes at in
Malibu in this little tiny Beach Nook
um during covet 20 of the brand new
episodes were done at home in a little
tiny it wasn't even anything like that
it was literally like made of plexiglass
with a little foam in it and I threw a
blanket over it
that's really neat it's really cool
right and I did a lot of major Rugrat
episodes wow is there ever a time where
you weren't able to film and what would
they do in those cases like let's just
say you had just given birth or
something like that they have to get an
episode out is there ever anything like
that or is it pretty laid back in terms
of their schedule and it's pretty laid
back because if let's say I'm let's say
I'm had a baby and I needed to you know
first of all it's not that hard to just
sit in a booth into your lines even if
you just have a baby I was that person
that
um started working pretty quickly right
away because I was known for just
bringing the baby with me like I didn't
want to that was my only thing was I
didn't want to leave my child
and be working to where my kid wasn't
getting what they needed so I would just
have like a nanny or an assistant and
they'd sit right there outside the booth
and then I would record if I needed they
need me I would just step out for a
second and I was just like so I never it
never compromised any of my personal
life like I just could do it anytime I
could do voice over most of the time it
wasn't if I had a flu like if I had a
flu or something and I needed to wait oh
they just say okay we'll get you record
next week so we'll skip this week and
we'll do your lines for this this week
next week so you'll do next week's and
the week after together so they just
kind of move things around it's like
super chill it's not like when you're
filming a movie yeah in your own
location and you have to be working with
the other actors and like if you can't
show up you're screwed right because the
whole everything yes but voiceover they
can record you a week later it's not
going to make or break anything wow if
Graham were doing a voice over for a
cartoon character what would the cartoon
character look like
wait what he would be really smart and I
would make him talk a little faster and
I'd say that he'd say listen everyone we
have something really important we're
going to negotiate here that's what I
would make you sound like you're smart
fast talking it's really cool I tell you
huh
yeah wow yeah I'd say that's pretty
fitting right there yeah that's one of
my favorite games my favorite games is
like if you were to put 10 faces and let
me hear 10 voices
pick an assignment yeah that's my funny
funny little game yeah I listened to a
podcast where you're talking about
making a voice of a pillow and how it
would sound oh it's like Kelly Clarkson
yep and I thought it was so accurate it
just like this really high pitched but
very pillow yes fluffy and she talks
like this Everything Is Beautiful put
your little bottom right here you know
what goes through your mind when you see
something like that and you put a put a
personality to it like oh my God it's so
much fun it's so much fun because you
can make anything have a voice like this
little plant could be like
oh we're just sitting here in the Sun
and it's beautiful you know what I mean
and this one would be like oh yeah I
really like it here in the sun he's a
little bit bigger let's hang out here in
the sun okay let's just do that what
would this key sound like oh the key
would sound like this let's go we're
Alexis let's put this in the car I mean
he's skinny a little so I would do this
one it just depends it's very fun oh
that is I wish I had that skill that
sounds fun it's really fun you know I
wanted to be a voiceover actor when I
was a kid I did so uh we'd get together
with my buddies and uh one of our
friends had a cell phone he was the only
one whose parents would like not check
the minutes that's when you had to pay
by minute and so we used to make these
prank phone calls and I would be the one
doing the voices and we call like
grocery stores Maybe on YouTube no gosh
no this was when uh I was in like sixth
grade seventh grade eighth grade like
somewhere around there
um but yeah so I would call up and I had
this character Aina makrovic oh let's
hear calling these grocery stores right
here hi my name is Ina Matt Griffith I'm
calling because I left something in the
grocery store like you know I used to
again yeah my voice got a little deep
but it would be better back then like a
lady I love it yeah and then I used to
call the school as my mom to get out of
school hi my name is Pamela Stefan
calling on behalf of Graham he's not
feeling well amazing so I really wanted
to get into voice acting I just thought
I had a cool knack for it no that's so
cool thank you I love that I actually
did this voiceover seminar I did two
things you guys should check out and get
you a link for I at least can get you a
link for the one woman show that the
voiceover seminar is summer I could get
you link for that too but um it was a
voiceover seminar and I did it because
people would ask that be like how do you
do it and I have a really cool voice and
he's like it's not just about having a
cool voice you have to be able to read
the lines like a real person people like
reading lines like drinking water don't
you're under the authority of the pup
you know you have to be able to be like
it matters but
um so I did do a seminar on voiceover
because people would ask and I filmed it
in front of a live audience and it's
it's like and I talked about the tips
tools how to's and it's pretty cool and
it's not expensive I did it like a
digital download thing so people can
learn and and I also did like which is
really interesting is I actually
interviewed a lot of the famous voice
over stars like and I asked all of them
like I talk about this in the seminar
but I asked a lot of like big Pro guys
like how you got a break and what's
really weird was none of them got a
break like normal like it wasn't like I
had an agent I booked a job everyone was
like I was singing at a wedding someone
heard my voice and said you wanted I was
in a play someone in my voice I was like
nobody went into voiceover like with the
intention of the voiceover they just I
was a comedian someone heard me every
single major voiceover star got it in
some random way it's really cool who's
out there looking for voices is it that
they work with TV and movies and they're
just sent out to Scout or are these
people just going about their day and
they find someone look I did a play and
some guy came to the play and was like
you're really good at your voices your
children's voices he was a voiceover
agent so he happened to be at the play
where I happen to be changing my voice
around and he's like you should try this
so he's like you never know
all I know is you
the more you're out there and the more
you do things the more you like say yes
to things the more openings for
opportunities come I guess it's the same
for dating right I'm supposed to be
going out more you're supposed to be
going out more I think so because I've
been like not it's like what's it go out
when it's raining but yeah if I want to
find my next husband are you on the apps
I am these are our favorite topics
I see you there
yeah I am on those apps it was driving
me crazy I'm not so good at them I need
I need I would have my assistant swipe
for me because I'm just like my
followers but does she know your taste I
mean
well my uh Julie's newer so she but my
other assistant Ace she kind of it she
kind of the same taste as me but it's
not just like the taste like the type
yeah I mean it's not like the type thing
it's more like now at this point in my
life it's more like when you hear people
talk about themselves Non-Stop and they
don't ask you how you are like
narcissists like that's just like a
highly allergic to narcissists like like
I'm looking for different things now
than I think I did when I was younger
like now it's really like
kind people people that are love animals
are kind emotional connections yeah yeah
yeah people that are like
deeper and connected so it's harder for
me with apps because
um I can't
it's hard for me to just look at a
picture now and read a few lines like
and then if I even get to where I have a
conversation usually they want to text
and text and text and text and I'm like
I don't want to text if you want to just
like have a quick FaceTime call that
would be better because then you could
see someone and I'm super intuitive and
I can see if like I'm you know for one
am I really attracted to them for two
are they really hearing me do they
really see me are they really connected
are they talking about things that
matter or they just like yo me and my
buddies you're growing around in this
boat wanna come like whatever just like
if there's something deeper like I love
animals I've done a lot of things or I
don't know I just look for deeper things
now and it's hard for me because
um I see everything like I think I'm
highly intuitive so I can see when
someone's over trying to sell themselves
and they're not really what they're
saying they are do you feel like maybe
it's intimidating that they that they
know who you are or do they not know
because I feel like it would yeah if I
meet someone and they go like oh my God
I saw you on Valley girl you're my
favorite and I'm like I can't date that
guy because it's too weird because
they're like bannering it's fangirling
and they're like it's one thing if
somebody's doing just as good in their
career no I mean if they're like their
world their life their careers they're
doing well so if they're just love what
I do and they and they want to know me
and and it's not like they live in
Pacoima on a boat dock and they're they
got a big fish in their picture they're
asking me to like move to Pacoima and go
fishing with them every day like we have
nothing in common yeah do you know what
I'm saying like if we have a lot in
common and like I'm a big animal person
I'm an animal activist and I do a lot
and so like with somebody that loves
animals I'm like that's a good I like
people that love animals that tells me a
lot about someone and someone who does a
lot of spiritual work that tells me a
lot about something and they kind of
like they would know how to walk a press
line if they had to but those are
important things because I go to like
big things sometimes you know what I
mean yeah I go to like beautiful events
and so I don't want to like
feel like the person I'm with is like
completely freaked out by all of it that
just wouldn't be a match so there's like
weird things I have to look for and I
just don't you know all right but if
they are a fan of your work wouldn't
that signal I'm a huge fan but wouldn't
that signal he's got a fiance oh
congrats but jacked up
but uh but if they're a fan of your work
wouldn't that also signal that that they
appreciate like what you do and like
your backstory in your career and like
and that is nice actually that would be
really beautiful as long as they were
feeling great about what they did and
they were thriving at what they did I
think if somebody's like
and I mean like comparable magnitude the
meaning like you know just both be doing
doing well in your life you know what I
mean or if you're both not doing well
but at least you match you know what I
mean yeah like for me I don't want to a
guy dated this guy who's a sweetheart
and I really liked him but
um we we really we were a match in some
ways it's like you're a very spiritual
guy we would go to some events and stuff
and he was a really nice guy but like he
lived in a behind a house in a little
Hut under behind a house and a thing and
I was like I can't I can't go there it's
not not like it's not like trying to be
superficial but it's just trying to be
like comfortable magnitude like you know
what I mean I've worked hard and I live
a certain way and I don't all of a
sudden like have to go from like an
inequality match so I mean you should be
like Matt so just like if somebody's has
no spiritual life and they don't believe
in God that's fine I do and so that's a
big disconnect so I think there has to
be like there has to be matches across
like important things and to me the
important ones are like spirituality
love of animals
um you know a person who's not a
narcissist who's just like I think it's
it makes it hard it does make it a
little hard yeah what's some of the best
relationship advice you've ever heard
the best I want to hear yours first the
best relationship advice Jackson yeah
well that's not a question I don't know
if this is like I mean it's a pretty
commonly agreed-upon thing that
communication is key and I'm a firm
believer that yeah yeah communicate
everything I think communication will
solve 99.99 of problems in relationships
I think that's a great answer yeah I
love that yes yes
you and I think laughter and then being
be able to be goofy and have fun I mean
oh this guy's a big guy
I think to me like being able to laugh
it's like whoever I end up marrying or
being with my for the rest of my life
partner person I just wanted to be fun
and funny and also sexy and hot yeah you
know what I mean like best friend slash
super hot for each other that's it yeah
and great communication and like just a
lot of like similar interests in the
world in the real big world and
important things yeah because work is
like
work is beautiful and I'm grateful for
my work but it's not at the end of the
day you want to like feel safe with your
people right and your career is here and
there and it goes up and down all the
time or whatever but at the end of the
day you want to feel safe in home at
home wherever home is yeah when Rugrats
was wrapping up how did you feel uh
towards that were you ever nervous of
like finding what the next thing was and
and
like progressing further with for my job
yeah yeah like there were there times
were
where I'm like wondering what my next
move is going to be right because yeah
right now I mean I have jobs yeah and
I'm I'm doing great and thank God but I
do Wonder like because I feel I'm being
called to something more big something
bigger and I do really want to do a
documentary
um because I had pretty interesting like
Journey with like even just personally
like my personal life it's not like I
would want it to be a scandal thing but
there's been a lot of Scandal in my life
with um
you know it's like my ex-husband was
married to Pam Anderson twice
my ex-husband was married Shannon
Doherty once my ex-husband was the guy
in the Paris Hilton tape you know what
I'm saying yeah but because of for some
reason and not just that in my own life
other things I've just had a lot of
really
wild things happen so I have a very and
people have dated like could you share
any of that like like what do you mean
like which like any any stories with
that or something that you would want to
include I mean okay like when I was in
my 20s I was madly love and I I had this
boyfriend whose name was John Eric Hexum
and he was this very very beautiful man
I look like you yeah there you go
[Music]
and he was a very beautiful man and uh
John Eric Hexum and
um I was younger than him and I was
madly in love with him and
um I think I was 22 and he was working
on a very big show at the time and he
put a pop gun up against his head and
shot it and it blew a piece of his skull
the size of a quarter into the middle of
his brain no brain dead and so that
happened and in a prop gun it was a Top
Gun is that just a for the shooting of
blank yeah but yeah though yeah a blank
has a blank close range if you put it
here it probably wouldn't okay but it
was here did he did he intend to do
damage or was this probably playing
around he was on the set and they said
he was playing around and he put it here
and the the blank has gunpowder wax and
paper yeah it's strong enough to shoot
through a piece of his skull the size of
a quarter to the middle of his brain so
oh my God he basically took him out and
so like that was a very challenging time
for me because I was only in my 20s
would use my boyfriend and
it was weird the whole thing was weird
and
um
yeah I mean I just had some really there
was a lot of trauma I've had some trauma
and also had some amazing things so life
is just pretty been pretty crazy journey
and you know I've I shared a lot about a
lot of that in that one woman show I
talked about it's called listen closely
and it's on digital it's on Amazon both
the seminar and listen closely listen
closely is like a one hour 15 minute one
woman autobiographical musical about my
journey
so I feel like I'm supposed to do the
documentary based on that one woman show
so if you guys see the woman show listen
closely there was a lot of things that
happened you I do talk about the Paris
Hilton thing and I do talk about
the Shannon Doherty stuff and I do talk
about how I met my first voice agent and
it changed my career I did talk about
John Eric shooting himself in the head I
actually reenact that whole thing in the
women's show so I try to be really real
about what happened and how my thought
process was during a lot of it and how I
just kept growing my spirit to be able
to handle all this yeah so I'm
feeling like the next thing I'm supposed
to do is I do like this book or this
documentary
plus there was a lot of stuff like
around the Conrad Hilton which is Paris
Hilton's little brother I mean you could
Google it and my family there's a lot of
drama around that there's just been a
lot of stuff in the middle of that I've
had this beautiful career and and my
love of animals so I just think there's
a lot of interesting things that I would
want to share my side of what happened
about a lot of things yeah
how did you cope through the the
shooting
because that I feel like is is just a is
a tough one to grasp because it was like
a bit of an accident very spontaneous it
was kind of like a dream okay it sort of
felt like I was in a dream I was like
I really almost couldn't believe it was
happening and then
but there were a lot of things that
happened up into that they're kind of
looking back I was able to journal like
I felt like he was a ticking time bomb
and he was gonna blow up I mean I like I
wrote it in journals like I feel like
John Eric is a taking time bomb and I
don't know when he's gonna go off and
then
there was another weird thing that
happened that I didn't remember until
recently I went to Ayahuasca which I
don't do drugs really I don't know if
you guys know what Ayahuasca I do I
don't I don't do drugs I've never done I
don't really do any drugs and I'm not a
drinker that's never my thing but I did
go do Ayahuasca because there's so many
amazing things I kept researching about
it and in that I had a very vivid memory
of when I was with John Eric in his room
in his bed and I couldn't stop crying
and it was like was happening I was
during the Ayahuasca when I was on
Ayahuasca and I was just remember I was
just crying crying crying I was like and
he was right there with me and I
remember it was like yesterday and what
was really weird was he died a week
later and I couldn't remember
that when I was
I didn't know why I was crying when I
was actually with him in real life a
week before he died and now I look back
and I was like I must have known
something like I knew something was
going to happen I wrote the thing he's
you know there's just a lot of really
weird things what what made you want to
do Ayahuasca what what about that peaked
your curiosity because I've seen a lot
of documentaries on it and hearing
people's experiences and it's
interesting but I would be I feel like
I'd be terrified terrified yeah okay
that's why I did it because for one my
daughter had done it when my younger
daughter did it she kept calling me
every night after her ceremonies and be
like Mom this is mind-boggling like
there's a lot of people just like you
there's women your age who have had
adult kids who have had lives and
they're very like you know they're
there's so many people just like you
normal regular people not drug addicts
not this not that and I kept thinking
yeah but I'm terrified first of all I
don't like to throw up
right yeah that's one of the first
things right like throwing up so it's
like do not I cannot and so I kept
saying no honey I could never do that
but I'm glad you're having a good
experience my daughter for her was very
healing and um
and so and the place she went to was
very very high-end and they really
educate you there you have to do classes
about it before you even do Ayahuasca
and then you do four days in a row but
you know four days in a row of Iowa four
days in a row right and so is that
healthy it's fine wow it's fine they
have like Medics and a medical yeah this
isn't in the United States in Costa Rica
that's where I did it and how long does
the Ayahuasca trip last
I mean I think it's longer the first
like the first three nights you go in
and you start there the ceremonies like
music and singing and like chanting
could start at seven and then you're
there to like
one or two in the morning at seven p.m
yeah and what are the demographics of
the people everyone I mean there were
like conservative like Couples from like
that have a cow Farm like really
conservative like they go to church
they're like super conservative couples
that were there I was like what are they
doing here and then they were like moms
and they were like young girls and like
older people and there was like older
men like in their late 70s I mean it was
really wide wide demographic it wasn't
like oh there's a bunch of wanting to be
sober out because there's a lot of
healing properties so it was really wild
but so when my daughter came back from
that trip she said Mom you should really
think about it I was like no I can't
never do that it scares the it scares me
so much and then I just kept thinking
about it and I kept researching and I
researched this guy Gabe mate this
doctor and he said like he's never seen
so much healing in his patients and he'd
he had dealt with people that were dying
and he dealt with people that were
terrible addicts he says he's never seen
the kind of recovery or healing that
came from
Ayahuasca so it was like and they kept
saying if it's calling to you and it
keeps calling to you then you gotta
listen because that's how mother
Ayahuasca works and so then I finally
said to my daughter yeah I'll do it I
couldn't believe I said it I couldn't
believe I did it and I did four days of
it did you go alone I went with my
daughter again she went again this was
months later wow yeah yeah it was what
how much does it cost for a four day
trip of that well this this place I went
to is like really nice it's called
rhythmia it's like a little bougier but
I wanted that because I wanted it to be
like very safer intimate really safe you
have to see the medic's office you you
have to do health forms you have to eat
a certain diet it's very strict it's a
medicine and so
um you know I don't know what that place
is like
7 000 for a week per person yeah but
it's for four days it's no it's a week
oh it's a week you do like oh you do
breath work you do meditation you do
yoga you do oh wow so it's a whole
Retreat it's a whole Retreat and one of
the activities that you do on the
retreat is the Ayahuasca aside from and
that's meditation that's right and the
last night of Ayahuasca you do from like
7 PM till the next day you're literally
watch the sun come up and you wake up
and you don't wake up you're like you're
awake through the night but are you
around sober people like there are
people like if you oh yeah did you see
people like freaking out you're in a
giant room like
a giant broom because 60 people massive
probably 60 people you're all in the
same room so you Vsauce had a great
documentary on it he went and did
exactly this and filmed the entire thing
I think I saw that one yeah I watched
all bunches but I didn't I didn't know
like
to me I I really wanted to
hear people's stories that never did
drugs because I was that person I was
like I want to hear from somebody who
was never a drug addict that's that's
what I was looking for online and I
couldn't find a lot of those
I don't know if I found any no because
that scared me I was like it's one thing
if you've done drugged and used to being
out of your mind but it's another if
you're never done drugs and that scares
me how did you find it to be healing
like in what way oh it's just so like
I'm saying it it takes you to part of
your brain that you can't really tap
back into usually breath work you can do
it with but like I was able to go back
to that moment lying in that bed with my
boyfriend who shot himself and I
remembered like a message like his
message was
um I believe in you
go do this that go do these things you
want to do like because he was like the
big star at the time he had this series
and I was like I was doing my own career
but I remember like
there was beautiful messages and I did I
went ahead and and followed through like
it's almost like he said you can do this
and that was way back at the beginning
of my career and I remembered things
about my mother that like it was hard
for me to connect with my mom all the
time for some reason my mom is beautiful
lady and was a good mom but
she was very like she'd look at me she'd
be like
what why is your hair messy here what's
going with that eyebrow or well it
wasn't like looking at me like I love
you it was like she she had a hard time
really seeing deeper was more like she
would great mom still but just couldn't
see me inside me
which was painful for me because I
always just want to be seen I want
people to see me and so one of the
messages I got was that
in Ayahuasca because you're like
tripping but you remember everything you
literally remember yourself throwing up
in a bucket you remember yourself
crawling to the bathroom you remember
like you remember like usually when
you're drunk you blackout you don't
remember not that I ever do that but
people when they're really messed up
they don't remember anything right you
remember everything during Ayahuasca and
so one of the messages was
like a shaman lady would ask me like
what are you feeling I'm like I feel
really nauseous
she's like what is that I'm like it's
fear she goes what is that fear I'm like
I'm just scared of everything and I
start sharing all these things but I'm
crying crying crying and then I just
said and I'm afraid like my mom's
getting older and I'll never get to
really have her see me and I start
crying like crying deep crying and then
all of a sudden she goes do you want to
dance with your mom and all of a sudden
I'm dancing with the shaman lady but
it's actually like I'm feeling like it's
my mother but my mother young and me
young and I'm crying and I'm like
connecting to my mother and then when I
come back to town after Ayahuasca my mom
is so present and I feel her like I've
never felt her and I don't know how that
worked but something shifted from the
Ayahuasca for me and when I see my mom
now
it's a very different weird thing it's
just weird do you think it's because
you're behaving and seeing things
differently or do you think yeah because
I had this Revelation that my mom has
always been able to connect with babies
and that came from the Ayahuasca once
the message was your mom connects to
babies and children she sees them
she has a hard time with adults for
whatever reason maybe they were too
painful for her but for some reason my
mom could connect and love children and
babies like she just loves them she had
five kids but adults probably scared the
out of her so
um I realized that in order to connect
with my mom I connect with her
like she sees the little kid so it's
like I don't know what happened just
something there was a weird Revelation
about my mom that was profound what's
your relationship with work look like
now are you still very gung-ho about
work you're still very excited to take
on more jobs and continue working for
the next five ten
to 15 20 years or what's your sentiment
I'm gonna be at all I'd like to make it
big in Hollywood
that was fun
the next 25 years yes well let me tell
you who are the grandparents on Rugrats
Boris Boris and uh
um
Oprah I remember when I used to watch
you
anyway I still really want to keep doing
beautiful I feel like there's so many
messages and things I've learned that I
want to find ways to put them out you
know what I mean if I can spare someone
some of the things I did I want to do
that I feel like there's so many
different voices I could still do
there's so many rules I still want to do
so there's a lot of like things I still
want to do I really do want to do a
documenting because I have all the old
footage of me like performing back in
the 80s when I would do like the Sunset
Strip and the whiskey and then all those
clubs back then and just like I have you
know videos of like I videotaped
everything back then so I want to use
all the live footage and so I really
want to do that I have to find the right
person to help me like a person to help
me put it together because it's too much
by myself but you know like a team that
does documentaries so I'm going to do
that that's one of my goals and I think
I want to write a book and there's other
roles I want to do that are like just
dope and cool and
and voice over it's Limitless you know
there's so many different voices I I
want to play with but so yeah I still
feel a drive I mean I definitely feel
like the last two years were kind of
chill for me
um even though I was working I was doing
Rugrats and other shows one's called
grimsburg I still think there's some
other really cool things I want to do
and and more speaking and more teaching
and more
um
more fun and more funny and more love
Yeah more how were you and what were
your thoughts about like saving and
investing throughout the entire process
was there any concern of like I don't
know how long this is going to last I
better save it like just in case because
I hear a lot about the industry could
either be like you're doing really well
one year and then there's no work for a
while you can make money when you're not
at all the next I mean there were times
where like I'd have to move out of my
house and go when my kids were little we
moved out of our house and went to go
live with the yogas because I was
running out of money the oakwoods is
like this apartment complex that a lot
of people would go stay at when they
were filming a show or they'd bring
their little families and stay in these
little apartments it was kind of fun it
was a lot of Industry people but there
were times where I had to move out of my
house and and take the kids when they
were little and because I was like oh
running out of money you know and
then everything just fly back and wants
to be making money again so I am very
aware about saving and
um being smart with money and um
you know I do have to you do have to
think about it because like I have money
but would I feel like if I want to just
retire and stop doing everything right
now I don't think I would feel ready to
do that
do you know I mean financially yeah I
don't think so I think I'd like to do
some jobs that were like just really
super big money to where I really don't
even have to think about it but right
now I think I would want to be more
stable there sure where are you
investing I hate stocks and all that
stuff like I literally like the only
money I put into stocks or into
I don't know what those are I don't even
know what they're called index ones it's
with USB what is that USB is that
the only money I've ever put is like a
little chunk of dough I would put into
that
like that money is down by 15 or 20
percent and it's been in there for two
years so I'm like wait wait so it's down
15 over two years in the last like
whatever since they I put it in it's
down from what the actual value market
has gone down yeah tell me about it not
over two years maybe two years yeah a
year so the s p is down about
10 year over year
over two years it's positive so right
now it's it's whatever over two years
okay then maybe it's been a year but
whatever money I took and I put it in
this thing
it's like you should do that and then
I'll invest that for you blah blah blah
it's down which means like I'm every
time I've ever put money in any of those
things that are play the market is
always down and anytime I was like I
think I need that they'd be like oh it's
down by this much and I'd be like I need
it and I told you to put it in nothing
unless it was really conservative and I
wasn't going to lose and it'd be down so
I like have no faith I think you just
gotta hold on a little bit longer I mean
overall the market saw a pretty big dip
over the past year when's it going up do
you have this I mean let me check uh
well did well today golden like date
basically where you can expect to go up
by yeah but then what then it goes up
and then it's usually it goes down so
you never really make it yeah well the
average is about seven to eight percent
a year over 20 years historically it's
about ten minutes no adjusted for
inflation sure you didn't specify that
but yes seven to eight percent yeah I
would do a cartoon voice adjusted for
inflation don't talk about it I would do
a little kid but hey let's talk about
inflation here
seven to eight percent a year 98 a year
Jack okay yeah well adjusted for
inflation it's 78 per year but if not
it's ten and for Rugrats do you continue
to get royalties yeah yeah you do well
then that's that's a retirement and you
get royalties from like I'm good I'm
fine I could retire yeah I mean I you
get royalties from like Two and a Half
Men I did like like 20 minutes to record
that song and I get gigantic royalties
on that song and I didn't even write the
song but it's uh in syndication that
show so it's a really big money thing
yeah Who would thought you know I did
that so long ago but it's great Chuck
Laurie has good projects one of the
stories that sticks with me for a theme
song is uh Danny Elfman who wrote um The
Simpsons theme song did it in the car in
15 minutes yeah submitted it and that's
it well that's how it is theme song yeah
when it's really good and it took me
15-20 minutes to cut the men menly men
it's so funny I I didn't realize until
recently that you were the voice for
that intro yeah but I always wondered
because his singing was too good like
there's no way I thought maybe it's like
he did you could see you like this but
you can't really sing very good so
I always thought maybe he was just like
really auto-tuned and they used him and
like just like fixed the voice because
it was like too good that was magic of
Me no yeah I know yeah can you do the
voice of Chucky can you imitate but can
you do any of the voices like can you
because you're so good at picking other
characters like doing it
could you or not
you know it's really funny Chucky I
don't really do huh I really don't do it
um there was a time on the show where I
did one of the other characters
I had a little
but um uh
I did do one other character on the show
just one or two episodes because the
person wasn't available or something but
um I don't want to like
it was probably supposed to be on the
download but I did do that one of the
characters once
um and uh but like yeah I don't do
Chucky which is really funny yeah
there's once in a while there'll be a
voice I don't do I mean I don't do men's
voices obviously you know but I just
used to do like I did uh Mrs impossible
Dash you have to get over on that you
know what's her name she does dash oh
Helen Hunt that's it's Holly Hollywood
yeah
Dash I want you to tell your dad some
you know she talks like that yeah so I
actually did this is impossible for all
the like pickups and the commercial
Studio tie commercial and uh so I do
things like that like they say can you
do Holly Hunter's voice I was like no I
can't do that she short talks like this
and I was like I can't do it but then I
did it and then I was like I guess I
can't do it oh they're gonna say can you
do shares they'll be like oh honey I'm
not sure how to do it you know so I
tried to share you know snap out of it
yeah that's good that's pretty good
right oh my God yeah so I do that but
it's a weird thing so it's certain
voices yes and there might be a voice
here and there I don't and I don't do
Chucky yeah but Nancy does great how
often do people ask you to do Tommy
Pickles all the time really yeah do you
ever get tired I have like workers at my
house and they'll be like oh you tell me
because you know be like yeah and then
I'll do it no not really it's pretty
sweet it's pretty sweet you know you see
them like light up like right yeah I do
the voice of my childhood I mean like
I'm like
um
if I'm in a restaurant I'm eating dinner
with somebody or you know and somebody
walks over the table I was like oh can
you do this I'm like man I'm on a date
it's probably not a good time you get
asked that while you're on a date I mean
there'll be times when people walk up to
you at a table like oh my God I I know
you and they're very sweet and I always
try to be very gracious but sometimes
I'll have to say I'm on a date so it's
not really appropriate for me so I'll
have to say that but I try to be nice
because there's a date doesn't encourage
you oh no it's okay go ahead sometimes
he wants the exact same thing sometimes
I've been waiting this entire time yes
you already set them up to ask the
question yeah right yeah he set it up no
I mean sometimes just to be sweet to
people you don't want to make people
feel terrible I don't like making people
feel bad it's hard enough for them to
walk up and say right you're the voice
of my childhood and that is a gift to me
but just sometimes there might be like I
might be in the middle of something and
it's really a bad time I might just say
oh I'm just in the middle of something
it's not a good time for me but thank
you you know just want to be gracious
yeah is there anything else that you
want to talk about anything else that we
you feel like we didn't hit I think
really honestly you guys should watch
the listen closely okay it's the one
woman I autobiographical musical it's on
Amazon and the one woman oh I do have
the voiceover seminar which is pretty
cool and I did have like some guest
people come and talk about voiceover and
I did share some interesting facts about
voiceover it's really kind of
interesting and I talk about my journey
a little bit too and because I really
think a lot of the journey is
is is being open and I talk about
offshoots like be open to like
somebody trying to point you to
something new that you might say no to
and again it is a fine line like we
talked about it you might you might say
notice I did say no one time I got
offered a partner Chuck uh Norris movie
to play his daughter in something and I
remember that I was like I'm not doing
Chuck Norris movie you know I passed on
it and I was so sad I passed on it
because they were in Calgary filming
riding horses and I was home in the
summer doing nothing because I had no
other jobs that came that summer and I
thought I was gonna have like so
sometimes it's like I find more
opportunities come by saying yes do you
know what I mean so I talk about things
like I talk about different kinds of
things but I like to teach people things
other than just how to do voices about
life so that it's life and art it's not
just like you're doing your work and
you're obsessed with your work because I
did obsess with my work and that's not a
fun way to live
well that sounds like me yeah but I like
it I love it you're doing something else
too yeah well I'm doing both but like
but I love work for me that's my Escape
it's just like loving work and I do too
I do too but
um I think um
if you have a box and you have like nine
squares and you have like work your
fiance and your animals and your his
Aquarius
aquarium and your blah blah and you put
them all in a box that your life should
be balanced and it shouldn't be like
99 just the work and then you give a
tiny bit I just think this needs to be
balanced for it all to really be good I
always feel like it can't be balanced
it's got to be like if you want to excel
at one thing you have to be like more
overweight yes that's true there are
times you want to be a little intense
but it'll make you crazy I mean the
thing is you don't want to get to where
you're just you feel like an empty shell
which is what I've experienced where I
was so obsessed with making my work
happen that I couldn't say no to people
I did things I didn't want to do I went
places I didn't want to go everything
was for work and I think I would want to
encourage people to
um to not give up yourself so much you
know what I mean it's one thing to be
ambitious which is cool and be driven
but don't give up
your integrity to yourself and that's
the difference do you know what I mean
yeah goodbye said yes the things I
didn't want to do or yes to hanging out
with people I didn't want to hang out
with because I thought I could get an
opportunity with that person and I was
like things happen I didn't want to have
happened then I'd be like that's that's
a line you shouldn't cross you should
I feel for myself I would take better
care of myself well thank you so much is
there anything else uh we'll link to
everything that you mentioned in the
description
really to daily Facebook each daily
Twitter I don't really do have much
Twitter but I like the tick tock it's
really Jude daily on Tick Tock and
Instagram and my website each daily.com
cool it's kind of fun well it'll all be
in the description thank you so much I
can't look out for screaming cry and do
Rugrats and grimsberg which I do with
Jon Hamm who's a great actor and yeah
it's gonna be fun good stuff thank you I
appreciate it you're welcome all right
thank you thanks guys
cool now we've got contact thank you
although you know what while we're on
the topic of being a Creator I gotta say
I know how overwhelming it could be to
see all the equipment that's out there
and think oh I gotta spend thousands of
dollars to get started up but thankfully
our sponsor of stream yard is there to
help so stream yard is a live streaming
Studio platform that helps you create
high quality content with just the click
of a button all you need is any camera
and an internet connection and you can
start streaming directly from your
browser what I really like though is
that you can stream to multiple social
media platforms all at the same time so
you could set it up once and then stream
to YouTube to Twitch to Instagram and so
on basically almost anything out there
you're gonna get your face out there
streamyard is the best way to start
creating content online and best of all
they also offer a free package so you
guys could get started today at the cost
of zero and look leveling with you guys
they've also been a huge supporter of
the podcast and have allowed us to take
a lot of trips and travel to some of the
guests that we otherwise just wouldn't
have really seen so if you guys
appreciate that and want to support us
and have something that's totally free
visit student yard Down Below in the
description to get started today thank
you so much stream yard we love you and
back to the episode